bonsoir à tous en attendant les
résultats la nouvelle donne politique
dans le reste de l'actualité aujourd'hui
tout d'abord le tennis bien sûr avec la
victoire à roland garros de rafael nadal
pour la troisième année consécutive
l'espagnol remporte les internationaux
de france définitivement à terre battue
et le central sont devenu son jardin
julien benedetto jean-marc notebook
il n'y a donc rien à faire face à ce
champion là à 21 ans rafael nadal
remporté pour la troisième année
consécutive roland garros seul bjorn
borg avait réussi cet exploit rêves
brisés pour réduire très derrière qui
devra encore patienter pour remporter le
seul titre du grand chelem qui manque à
son immense palmarès
voilà moi je suis heureux mais un peu
déçu pour rogers elles sont moins grands
paniers c'est un ami il méritait la
victoire
c'est vraiment un grand champion un peu
ça malgré une bonne dizaine de balles de
break contre lui rappelle nadal empoche
le premier set
l'espagnol est fidèle à lui même
toujours aussi stupéfiant physiquement
en face ce n'est pas le grand federer
mais au bout de cette course folle
le numéro un mondial parvient à égaliser
à un set partout
porté par un court central
majoritairement acquis à sa cause
mais le problème est insoluble
avec ses grands coups liftés nadal met
une pression de tous les instants qui
empêche le suisse d'imposer son jeu de
fond de court j'avais peur vraiment
faire ce que je voulais c'est un peu
dommage bien simple on sait ce que j'ai
dans le troisième set nadal se détache
rapidement
c'est le tournant du match federer
baisse la tête comme s'il accepté la
domination de son adversaire après trois
heures de jeu une énième faute directe
du numéro un mondial offre le tournoi au
roi de la terre battue comme l'année
dernière nadal cinq fois dont 4 août
2005 2006 2007 triple couronne pour
l'espagnol
et vu son incroyable niveau de jeu on
voit mal comment cette suprématie pour s
arrêter le rugby et le stade français
qui a célébré sa victoire dans les rues
de la capitale mais également à roland
garros cet après midi les joueurs
parisiens ont remporté hier soir une
victoire au bout du suspense sur
l'équipe de clermont qui a longtemps cru
repartir enfin en auvergne avec le
bouclier de brennus arnault compte
annick rivoire dans le viseur de madame
pas de tennisman
mais de beaux rugbymen le stade français
champion de france hier soir
héros du court central cet après-midi le
temps d'une ovation
alors le quinze de france federer ou
nadal
une affreuse
vers l'avant et fait la fête
étonnante espagnol xavi
quatre heures plus tôt l'avenue des
champs-elysées et rose de monde le 15
parisien présente le bouclier de brennus
à ses supporters c'est l'hystérie
un treizième titre remporté dans la
douleur car à la mi temps c'est
clairement qui mène 9-0 grâce notamment
à la botte affûté de james le stade
français court derrière les auvergnats à
un quart d'heure de la fin clermont mène
par six points d'avance paris tente
alors le tout pour le tout pour recoller
au score et ça marche i shot aplati une
première fois la 77e minute avant que ce
hameau en puissance au foie la victoire
au stade français dans les ultimes
secondes
scénario cruel pour clairement
inconsolable
paris est en liesse après l'est et le
nord en fin de semaine c'est au tour du
sud ouest et de l'auvergne d'être placés
en alerte orange météo france prévoit en
effet des orages important dans 13
départements comme vous le voyez sur
cette carte la loire le puy de dôme le
gers encore le lot et garonne sont
concernés
et cela jusqu'à demain matin prudence
donc le tgv est et tout à l'heure ce
matin à paris et à strasbourg
aujourd'hui les usagers ont pu acheter
leur premier billet premier test
grandeur nature pour ces nouveaux
voyageurs qui semblaient séduits par la
modernité de leurs nouveaux moyens de
transport ambiance avec bruno team 6 et
marc langue à nagano en voiture 7h15 ce
matin le premier tgv strasbourg paris va
partir ce matin j'étais déjà debout j'ai
fait tout ce qu'il fallait pour être
reconnu je suis très content c'est en
émotions c'est formidable
2h20 de trajet au lieu de 4 heures un
événement très attendu
c'est une occasion unique et ce doit
être souligné paul l'allier avec les
comités gérer apple ce qu'attendent tous
les voyageurs c'est le passage à la
grande vitesse
nous avons convaincu qu'en version 320
km
les galères des corail sont oubliées
l'occasion de reprendre goût au train
passion du petit dimanche à paris
aller-retour savais que j'avais déjà
fait une fois l'aller-retour en corail
et c'était très éprouvant faisait le
chemin de colmar à à paris je m'étais
izard alors aujourd'hui je suis payé ma
vie ça que rené sako veux tous vous les
vitesses
alors aujourd'hui c'est un non événement
pour moi vingt-cinq ans que l'est de la
france attendait son tgv pour certains
ça va changer la vie
le dg vient de faire nous permet de
faire un aller-retour dans la journée
pour voir nos petits-enfants nous en
fait on a deux enfants paris donc ça
tombe bien
9h35 arrivé à paris
un peu plus tard c'est un train à grande
vitesse allemand qui arrivent gare de
l'est grâce à la ligne est entre la
france et l'allemagne
les distances sont rétrécis l'europe des
chemins de fer est en marche
le bac philo c'est pour demain ce lundi
cinq cent mille candidats sont attendus
dans les salles d'examen dans ses
derniers instants à chacun sa méthode un
peu de roland garros pour les uns un peu
de soleil pour d'autres mais il ya
toujours aussi les petites révisions qui
rassure nabila taboury et régis mater
ont suivi aujourd'hui quelques candidats
parisiens dans cette dernière ligne
droite les pieds dans l'herbe la tête au
bac
anja baptiste et leurs camarades se sont
mis au vert cet après midi histoire de
tuer le stress mais rien à faire
à 24 heures de l'épreuve de philo la
boule au ventre est là et bien là
ils en font même des cauchemars il
manquait propos pendant et après j'avais
pas là mais au fait je n'avais pas et du
coup pour rester philosophe une seule
méthode bronzer au soleil se libérer
l'esprit parce qu'on peut faire d'autre
autre chose que réviser l'histoire de
lire un bouquin retour au lycée pour un
lien et ses copines leur établissement
reste ouvert même louis gender
aujourd'hui comme tous les autres jours
depuis deux semaines ils viennent qui
révisé pour la concentration selon eux
la salle de classe c'est mieux que la
chambre ait pas la télé il n'y a pas le
lit pour dormir et avec soleil sont
studieux les révisions il est des bus à
huit heures pour les finir parfois à 22h
objectif décrocher leur bac scientifique
quitte à délaisser parfois les matières
littéraires l'histoire ya le livre comme
ça à prendre les coiffes 3 les maths
dérives comme ça sim et de se dire on a
bossé on n'a pas eu tant pis on fera
mieux l'année prochaine on devra bosser
pour les prochaines que désire j'ai
foiré mon bac j'ai raku tubes pour une
france à vendredi un coin c'est super
important et l'esprit tranquille ils ne
l'auront que vendredi prochain ce sera
la fin des épreuves écrites
en attendant ce soir ils font relâche en
afrique la situation dans l'est du tchad
et une situation d'urgence et le message
qu'adresse est bernard kouchner en
visite dans l'un des camps de réfugiés à
la frontière du soudan
le conflit du darfour était au coeur du
déplacement du ministre français des
affaires étrangères celui-ci plaidera
pour un couloir humanitaire auprès des
autorités soudanaises dans les heures
qui viennent
ono bernard dominique derda effet des
bureaux pour faire avancer le dossier
carrefour sa priorité
bernard kouchner s'est donné quatre
jouer le ministre des affaires
étrangères a déjà obtenu deux avancées
la première le président tchadien
approuve le déploiement d'une force
multinationale pour sécuriser la zone
frontière entre le tchad et le soudan
avec le temps la crise qui secoue le
darfour s'est déplacé à l'est du tchad
dans cette région quatre cent mille
réfugiés s'entassent dans des camps
deux cent trente mille soudanais qui ont
fui lé darfour mais également 160000
tchadien poussés à l'exode par les
violences frontalières pour ces réfugiés
le président tchadien également accepté
une autre demande française
la mise en place d'un pont aérien des
militaires français vont donc
ravitailler la zone des camps à l'est du
tchad
il faut au plus vite dans les quinze
jours qui viennent transportait plus de
nourriture dans la région que nous avons
visité hier parce que la saison des
fruits ronds et les pistes où la même
même hier c'était déjà difficile
impraticable dans trois semaines
bernard kouchner est attendu ce soir au
soudan pour proposer la mise en place
d'un dispositif similaire au darfour
directement avec une zone sécurisée et
un corridor humanitaire ont voté
également en belgique aujourd'hui pour
renouveler le parlement les premières
estimations de la victoire aux chrétiens
démocrates ce qui constituerait un
revers pour la coalition libéral
socialiste qui est au pouvoir depuis
huit ans les images de cet accident en
belgique justement en autocar
transportant des touristes anglais a
percuté une maison et s'est en partie
effondré
trois habitants de cette maison une
vingtaine d'occupants du car ont séché
blessés l'accident a eu lieu dans une
station balnéaire du nord ouest du pays
à middelkerke eu exactement
direction l'espace maintenant avec la
navette atlantis après un décollage
réussi de cap canaveral en floride
elle devrait arriver dans un peu plus de
deux heures maintenant à destination la
station spatiale internationale met en
route
atlantis a subi quelques dommages sans
conséquence selon la nasa
explication florence bocchia c'est une
petite déchirure
un accroc d'une dizaine de centimètres
sur la couverture thermique de la
navette que le bras qu'elle est
manipulée 406 a découvert plusieurs
heures après le décollage des morceaux
de mousse isolante ont également été
arraché du réservoir extérieur mais pour
le moment ce problème n'inquiète pas l'
agence spatiale américaine
il leur est pareil de plusieurs manières
à mieux tirer la couverte eric pour
réparer la croatie ou bien superposer
une pièce sur l'autre rue et nous avons
aussi la possibilité de faire couler une
colle spéciale dans l'intérêt
pour examiner les dégâts les astronautes
d'atlantis attendront d'être amarrée à
la station spatiale internationale
dans deux heures l'équipage doit sortir
trois fois dans l'espace et poursuivre
la construction de l'avant poste orbital
l'émission doit durer 11 juin au tour en
france avec ce bilan difficile parfois
pour les stations de ski la saison et et
vous le savez une nouvelle fois marquée
par le manque de neige les plus touchés
sont les stations de basse altitude
certaines envisagent donc le pire être
obligé de fermer définitivement leurs
domaines skiables déjà le cas
d'abondance située en haute savoie sur
place denis sébastien philippe évêques
réchauffement climatique ou pas ils
veulent continuer à skier en vert et
contre tous ses habitants d'abondance
n'accepte pas la décision prise par leur
conseil municipal d'arrêter la station
ce matin ils étaient environ 300 à
manifester parfois déguisés dans les
rues du village que sont le ski c'est
plus rien su rien on peut pas remplacer
du jour au lendemain le ski par d'autres
activités ou conserver la faction
d'abondance
sinon on est mort
la station d'abondance c'est une dizaine
de remontées mécaniques pour une
clientèle familiale avec un handicap de
plus en plus criants une altitude plus
élevée entre 1000 et 1700 m le domaine
avait été construit en 1964 si la
décision de fermeture se confirme ce
sont donc 40 années de glisse qui vont
se terminer
c'est vraiment là gâchis parce que je
connais quand même très bien notre notre
installation elle est pas délabré elle a
été bien entretenue jusqu'à maintenant
on a fait le maximum et je pense qu'elle
n'est pas en fin de vie pour répondre à
ses administrés en colère le maire
avance deux arguments les problèmes
d'enneigement d'abord la station n'a pu
ouvrir qu un mois cet hiver et le
déficit chronique des remontées 600000
euros de pertes cette année on n'arrive
plus à payer tout ça je vous dis ça
représente plus à rome
ça fait plus de 50% du budget principal
dépôt mais moi je sois plus du tout et
c'est en voit plus comment faire et
abondance n'est pas la seule commune
concernée en haute savoie
le conseil général a recensé une
douzaine de petites et moyennes stations
dans la même situation
d'autres pourraient donc à leur tour
arrêté le ski dans les prochaines années
et puis c'est un record mondial qui
était battu aujourd'hui pour une vente
d'objets ayant appartenu à napoléon le
sable qui la portait lors de la bataille
de marengo a été adjugée 4 millions huit
cent mille euros
record battu donc il y à quelques heures
lors d'une vente aux enchères à
fontainebleau et ving holman mathieu
dreujou c'est une formidable bataille
que se sont livrée les collectionneurs
de souvenirs pour obtenir l'objet de
leur rêve en faisant monter les enchères
jusqu'à 4 millions 800 mille 754 euros
ils ont montré que napoléon a encore de
la valeur il faut dire que l'objet a de
quoi susciter l'intérêt
ce sabre bonaparte le porter à la
bataille de marengo un combat difficile
contre les autrichiens qu'il gagne de
justesse empereur napoléon l'offre à son
plus jeune frère jérôme
pour le remercier d'avoir accepté
d'épouser catherine de gutenberg une
alliance très politique qui permet de
consolider le pouvoir rester dans la
famille jusqu'à ce jour il est classé
monument historique
donc aucun étranger ne pouvait
l'acquérir finalement le sabre non
seulement ne sortira pas de france mais
restera dans la famille bonaparte un des
descendants de jérôme qui souhaite
rester anonyme a proposé l'enchère la
plus forte
enfin la 158e édition du prix de diane
rendez vous annuel du galop et
d'élégance en tribunes de nombreux
chapeaux comme le veut la tradition sur
la piste un nom anglais wes queen est
une pouliche française monté par un
jockey italien qui remporte la course
jusque là se déroulait bien sûr sur
l'hippodrome de chantilly
voilà pour ce coin sur l'actualité de ce
dimanche tout de suite vous retrouver
élise lucet david pujadas pour la soirée
électorale les résultats de ce premier
tour des élections législatives belle
soirée à vous